Stalin same thing Stalin the Great
Father right wise man at the helm of the
ship of the state this is after the wall
came down some old man kissing a gilded
statue of Stellan before it's going to
be before it's going to be torn down
there he is with happy children and not
the children that his policies starved
to death as you as you might well
imagine there he is in his military
uniform sitting on what's all for all
intents and purposes our throne and this
is this is really an uncanny one it's
very positive right that Hitler is or
still in this head of state he's in this
hellish mandorla of fire perfect with
God the Father at his head that's Lenin
you know who people still who people
still revere you may know and perhaps
you don't that I was nominated to be
rector of the University of Glasgow and
so which is an honorary position and
today yesterday the different candidates
put up their manifestos and and the
student newspaper put them up and then
wrote analysis of the manifestos which
were biased and they were appallingly
biased in one sided and I wrote and told
him that they said well we have a
perfect right to our political opinion
and I thought yeah well for sure but you
know you are journalists after all and
maybe you could be just trying to tell
what's happening like no no no there's
none of that and they said that one of
the candidates that they that they
clearly recommended who seems to be a
person who's perfectly heroic in his own
right I mean he's taken on very many
difficult legal cases and worked for the
oppressed and downtrodden who clearly
exist it was either him or another
candidate doesn't really matter that
they described as bolshie an unspoken
bolshie meaning bolshevik like it's like
well you know he's appropriately
it's like it's no different
than saying well he's appropriately Nazi
like like what the hell is that I mean
there were 50 million people that were
killed in the Soviet Union by the bull
she's and maybe twice that many in in
China not that says nothing about
Cambodia and all the other places there
were radical left bloodbath you think
it's cute to call someone bull she she
it's appalling it's appalling it's not
some fashionable thing that you do it's
the participation and some of the
deepest intellectual morasses of evil
that human beings have ever managed to
create and yet it's fashionable it shows
you what the universities are worth well
there's the downside of Stellan yeah
stellen is hangman that sort of cartoon
would have gotten you killed in the
Soviet Union
there's Stalin as Satan himself in a
stained glass representation there's a
statue of Stellan covered with red paint
for the blood after the wall came down
there Stellan as what it's very much
like Medina's Satan right you look at
that and it's exactly the same
archetypal idea there's the Americans
going it had a cap in hand to get a
little largesse from papa Stalin that's
a painting of the Communists forcibly
collectivizing the productive farmers in
the soviet union in the early 1920s the
kulaks right everything from whom they
stole and raped them and murdered them
and shipped them off to siberia and
killed them and wiped out the productive
farmers of the Soviet Union and then
starved six million Ukrainians to death
and there's some poor kid in the 1930s
whose ribs are showing you know taking a
bath in this pot with his eyes wide and
you know he's one of the fortunate ones
because he's still alive it's like
yeah cute pretty fun
fashionable lovely